a week after Wall Street Journal
reporter Evan gerskovic was detained in
Russia accused of Espionage while on a
reporting trip U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken made an important
statement in my own mind there's no
doubt that he's being wrongfully
detained
those two words wrongfully detained when
officially applied to U.S national held
abroad rev up the process for securing
the person's release Wall Street Journal
editor-in-chief Emma Tucker told Face
the Nation on April 2nd that she hopes
the designation will come quickly and
wants that official recognition comes
things can then move a bit more rapidly
with an official determination on
gershkovich's detention pending let's
look at the factors the state department
considers to decide if an American has
been wrongfully detained why it matters
and how it could help secure
gershkovich's release
according to the state department
wrongful detention means that someone is
being held on discriminatory or
arbitrary grounds the United States
government does not automatically go to
bat for every American citizen who is
held overseas being designated as
wrongfully detained means the United
States government believes you should
not be there and that you should be
returned Louise radnovsky covered
Brittany greiner's arrest and release in
2022 and reported on her wrongfully
detained designation the state
department says this isn't a legal
determination rather it's an assessment
of circumstances but it still prompts an
important process within the US
government once an individual receives
it the case transfers from Consular
Affairs to the office of the special
presidential Envoy for hostage Affairs
or spiha currently run by Roger D
Carstens this office is singularly
focused on negotiating the release of
hostages and Americans wrongly detained
in other countries biha has the option
to start negotiations for a release and
can act as an advocate for detainees and
their families the designation also
makes more resources available to the US
to negotiate a release including the
option to impose special sanctions on
the country where the person is being
held being considered wrongfully
detained effectively commits the power
of the US government to securing the
person's release and return to the
United States a number of Americans are
detained abroad every year and they're
all entitled to Consular assistance but
in cases where somebody is considered
been wrongfully detained then their case
is handled differently it's handled by a
different part of the state department
the state department says the assessment
to determine if someone is wrongfully
detained varies depending on the case
but it always considers a set of 11
criteria determined by a law called the
Levinson act which was put in place in
2020. those 11 criteria include factors
concerning the individual like if he or
she is being held for being a U.S
national or for x exercising freedom of
the press officials also examine whether
the U.S has evidence of Innocence or if
the detainment is a move to influence
U.S policy other criteria focus on the
situation like if the detainee is being
held in inhumane conditions or if the
individual has been denied due process
a case doesn't need to meet all of these
criteria to receive the determination
the state department doesn't share full
details on the process or the details of
individual assessments but a state
department spokesman said 30 to 40
people are currently held with a
distinction there's only so much I can
say about the process for determining
whether an American is wrongfully
detained it is a deliberative process
one of the Hallmarks of wrongful
detention cases is concern for secrecy
in a sense that negotiating
in public is not necessarily helpful in
the majority of cases and so a number of
details presumably because they're
considered to be sensitive are not made
public or ever made public but certainly
not while conversations are ongoing
some recent detainees who have returned
home like Griner and Trevor Reed had
received the wrongfully detained
designation but it doesn't guarantee
release
Paul Whalen an ex-marine charged with
Espionage in Russia who has the label is
still being held more than four years
after his detention it's important to
remember that being designated
wrongfully detained does not magically
unlock a cell door in any way what it
does is carry implications for the
United States government
would join the US's list of wrongfully
detained Nationals if the state
department makes That official
determination The Wall Street Journal
and the US government have vehemently
denied the allegation by Russia and have
demanded the reporters immediate release
Evan was doing what reporters do and
what he did very well he was out there
Gathering news talking to people
reporting providing an eyewitness
account of what's going on inside Russia